and that's that is something you know
and
they say you always look for what you
didn't have before you know i in a in my
prior marriage you know
my my
at the time wife was always basically
saying why are you going to the gym you
know you're already strong enough and
not understanding that this is a life
long
let's do this so jaren moff there's a
few people in the comments uh ryan that
are offering some opinions i think this
is a great topic if you guys want to
click through on the stream you're glen
and hop in let's you know let's kind of
chop up some of these things because
um there's a few things that are coming
up like jared saying he's completely
bought into her frame so she has the
upper hand in the relationship
and that is a key point right there from
your book that uh i'm actually surprised
that neither of us brought up to this
point was being in her frame versus
being in my frame that's what you are
you you talk a lot about and
you know i
i don't like that
i hesitate to use the term alpha male
i've had friends of my close circle
refer to me
as such i don't like to refer to myself
as such hit no man who is the king has
to say that he is the king
type thing right
but i find myself for the first time in
my life
adjusting to her frame and i know that
something you vehemently oppose
and i don't think unjustifiably so um
you know and i find myself you know
the reason why i was
i don't like to brag the reason why i
was as successful as i was in
afghanistan about predicting the future
is because it's the same thing i do now
working in
finance and working um in the stock
market is i
i
make
scenarios and i account for any and
like no surprise is a good surprise i
hate surprises there are no surprises
and so this is the first time where all
of my scenarios find me adjusting to a
female's frame
um and this is also the first time when
i'm seeing someone who makes more money
than me usually i make multiples of what
the female i'm seeing makes and in this
particular instance female makes
multiples of what i make um
sharon how's it going
hey how you doing so that's jaren he's
men shrine in the live chat he'll also
be on with moth later on um
doing his stereo show we got ryan in the
house which is a certified
hypnotherapist
also a good dude
oh you're gonna get us he's also been in
the chat offering some you know opinions
and views which i think you should hear
i think this is a really good
conversation and there's times where i
have call-ins where it's like okay i
need to move on to the next one this
isn't this isn't a great conversation
this is one that i think that deserves a
little bit more attention so i have no
problem spending some more time on you
know tonight's show too
yeah i think the first thing that i
notice and guys in the chat can chime in
too but it seems like you're almost too
confident with her which that was kind
of the red flag that got me going like
all right um anything that rich asked
you you had an answer for it like oh no
no but not this one not this one and
we've seen a lot of callers that come
into these shows and they do exactly
that and sometimes it's really hard to
step outside of yourself and take a look
at yourself from an objective point of
view because unlike you i'm really
analytical too and my work like i'm
always i'm always on on the ball but in
my own relationships looking back at the
past sometimes you're like all right
well you know what i i
had a hand to play in that screw up
and looking at yourself at least things
that i've seen in me is like when i'm so
sure of something in a relationship
usually it's kind of like
all right um i i'm sure you have plenty
of experience in the middle with the
military background and whatnot but
it seems like
it seems like that you're so happy and
so confident and so self-assured in this
relationship that you're looking past
things that might be leading indicators
of things to come for example you
mentioned that she does make more money
than you she has alluded to the fact
that she'd like you to start your own
business aka his mom said make more
money um that she's fitter than you and
the way the way you talk about her
indicates to me that you're in the frame
that she has the upper hand on you that
she's perceived as higher value than you
and it doesn't matter if it's true or
not if she thinks that in her head then
i see this starting to unravel at some
point and that's that's just my two
cents so here here's ryan's comment he
said if she's hotter at 46 than most of
his other girls he's been with he's got
to work on his own self-worth value so
he can feel deserving of hotter younger
women
and that's possible yeah that's one
thing that i've seen with a lot of
military guys is
they're going in the military and they
end up with whoever happens to take them
rather than women who are actually good
for them and i did this myself married a
woman in the air force
first woman that was like actually
you know dealt with me right well that
was your first date terrible exactly
exactly
but anyways
point being that i see this over and
over and over again with guys in the
military is that they don't actually
have a whole lot of self-worth when it
comes to what they feel
they deserve
so that was definitely true ten years
ago uh and i think that's true and the
thing is that i'm seeing the same
pattern because you should be able to
you're a good looking guy you're 36
years old
you've got all the stability indicators
that every woman is looking for
you do right and you're playing around
with a woman who's 10 years older than
you
who's playing mommy
that's not really is she's making more
money she's running things she's you're
in her frame so
kind of is in a lot of ways the frame
thing is the is the biggest problem that
you've got with this entire relationship
in my view
correct rich that is that that is
correct or or rather i'm sorry hypnosis
for men please continue your thought i
didn't interrupt you i apologize no no
you're quite fine you're quite fine so
here's the deal like if you actually
felt that you could get good quality
women who are your age and younger or a
good mother and everything else
you wouldn't be on this show asking rich
if it was okay to date a woman who was
10 years older than you and you were in
a frame of making more money
so i i guess i guess
there's a that's a fair point um
my thoughts have been more
are there exceptions to the rule
is
yeah yeah well you want this to be an
exception so that you feel more
comfortable about it because your
intuition right now is warning you going
yo zach you sure you want to do this is
this going to go the right way well and
into that let's do that let's call this
guy this this bald bearded man with a
wicked ass beard on youtube and say hey
do you think this is a good idea rich
you know let's let's ask his opinion oh
wait now there's three other guys on
with him let's see what they have to say
sort of thing right mom
the thing that i wanted to ask her the
thing that i keep coming back to is the
first thing you said at the beginning
where she goes
you know you're pulling over 200k like
that's not exactly slouching around and
she's doing multiples of that
and so her question of why don't you
start your own business is not it's when
are you going to start making some more
money it's when are you going to get on
my level it's when are you going to get
to a place where i look at you as my
provider and my financial best and
we seem to be getting away from that a
little bit no i'm so glad that you
brought that up because this is this is
something that i dialed in to very
quickly after she first mentioned that i
didn't say anything about it in the
moment as a rule i try not to say
anything in the heat of the moment i'll
go back i'll think about it for a day or
two if it's still bothering me then i'll
say something about it uh and so this is
in short how the conversation has
evolved over the last several months
which was i brought this to our
attention you know essentially you know
anyone who knows me is not going to shy
away from the fact that i don't exactly
have a low opinion of myself
and
it seemed odd to me that she didn't seem
to have a high opinion of me
and we can only go with how people
explain themselves which was that it
wasn't that at all it wasn't that i
needed to be
the breadwinner in the relationship it
was no i've started multiple businesses
over the last two decades like what you
know your industry why aren't you making
more money for yourself you're working
as a consultant yeah yeah but the
question is
is just a big word salad for i need you
to make as much money i need to be
better i need you to do better like i
need a man that's better than me but
more than that the the whole like all we
can do is judging by the words that's
100 [ __ ] you know about that
especially if you're working in an intel
you don't [ __ ] pay attention to what
they say
you can't you fundamentally can't and
you know that right but they're right
they're looking they're saying hey you
are she is telling you that she is
wondering why you're not better than you
are
those are the words that are coming out
about it she wants you to be better yeah
she loves she loves the d zach like
that's why she's with you i mean you're
obviously doing something right in the
bedroom but she's also telling you in
another breath when you're not in the
bedroom hey it would be really cool if
you started a business and made as much
money as i did so i can look at you
instead of down towards you and it's not
our fault it was right that reaction
that you're having of like oh like this
is that that i was i'm not saying you
were hurt but like oh like i didn't want
to say anything clearly you got a
reaction out of you you didn't like that
she brought that up that stirred
something in you that you were
frustrated about but again like this
this is women in a nutshell man like
this is something that we have to come
to respect
so
i'll go ahead please hit mrs man please
things uh number one the fact that you
had to bring it to her attention
is kind of like a hey boss just wanted
to let you know
just saying right and number two there
was a guy by the name of ian ironwood
who's one of the very early amendosphere
writers and he was a situation where he
was his wife was the breadwinner in the
family right
now they deliberately did things to put
him in headship of the relationships and
she deliberately did things to make him
the head of the household
this woman doesn't seem like she's doing
that to you
if you want to test that theory
have you guys talked about
where do we stand are we going to live
together has any of that come up
oh it absolutely has and who who was it
that brought it up you or her no me
okay you brought it up you're in her
frame okay so carry on
the
there i i have plans for the future of
our relationship um that i don't feel
like broadcasting on youtube okay uh
you've got plans but does she have plans
is it the financial aspect is she kind
of like a sugar mama type situation
because i i'm down in latin america and
i've talked to guys in the group i've
dated older women they give me like
access to cars or like nice beach
properties and stuff but it's like it's
not going anywhere we both know that
so in those situations she's just
throwing money at you
this is a relationship quite quite quite
the converse in fact uh and and what i'm
about to say may draw some ire um but it
is what it is
um
we both
opened up a few months ago with each
other after we'd been seeing each other
for for a little while for a few months
we opened up with each other about you
know our past because i think context is
important
and she had shared that basically she
had felt like she'd been taken advantage
of in past relationships to the degree
that you gentlemen are referring to
and so something i said to her is that
hypothetically looking down the road if
you and i ever got married and i brought
this up i said listen i have my own
money you have your own money i would
you you have more than i do i would
volunteer sign a prenup because i want
you to know
i don't want or need what you have
i'm interested in you as a person
so
a lot of the stuff that you're talking
about here zach like this is not the
relationship of an unplugged man running
the frame of the relationship you know
making himself his mental point of
origin
this is a guy that's that's that's
none of those things can i can i make it
a little bit more brutal for you to make
it yeah go ahead ryan yeah please do
she's the husband looking for a wife and
you're a perfect wife right now yeah
i mean
oh hang on a second dude that's the
title of the clip that's that's
let's go
clip that [ __ ]
i mean
call me
call me confident enough in my own
masculinity that i'm like
okay if that's if that's the role you
want to play in the relationship fine
and you're welcome to own that like
there's nothing nobody says you can't do
that right
you're a grown-ass man you can do
whatever you want to this is some
advanced [ __ ] exactly this is nice
this is definitely not the bunny slopes
definitely on the bunny slopes here
right if you're gonna this is the double
black diamonds in colorado
right but if that's the way you want to
go down things then you can right just
understand that you have a very hard
road to run
and you're gonna have to get her to buy
into the idea that you are the wife in
the relationship rather than the husband
because most women especially accomplish
women who are her age and older they
want a husband they want a man to lead
so you're gonna have to figure out how
to do that without having the power in
their relationship without having the
money in the relationship
so without going too much into over
sharing uh one of the things that um
we'll just say one of the things that
make that makes our dynamic interesting
is that um
in terms of uh who takes control and
this in our in various scenarios uh i
basically always take points
amongst other things yeah i mean that's
pretty common though right like we know
like one of the things you'll always
find is that
career women love to be dominated in the
bedroom like one of the things that you
like pantsuit women 40 year old women i
mean
marching around all day barking orders
for they for 30 minutes or 10 minutes or
whatever they get to put that aside and
uh yeah that's not a secret but i mean i
see what you mean but i mean i think
it's it's a lot more common it's a
little bit more than that um we're not
trying to pop the bubble here zach we're
just we're just trying to make sure that
you march into this with your eyes wide
open no
like that's what you're
right like right that's why you're
called in tonight right we're doing milt
we're doing mdmp military decision
making process we're doing co-dev course
of action development course of action
analysis we're doing wargaming
and so
well let's just say i'm always looking
for people to play the opposing force to
present to me a strong counter argument
for why i should not pursue the course
of action i'm strongly considering
pursuing well i mean you have to do it
anyway you're just you know you're just
asking for that that's not true that's
that's i think in this case you need to
present the strong argument as to why
you should pursue this
let's leave that aside let's leave that
aside for just a moment if you want the
strong argument why you shouldn't pursue
this number one you're walking into a
situation where you are going to be
submissive to her in the relationship
until unless you figure out some way to
get headship in the relationship even
though she has more money
and she accepts that frame your sol
which is highly unlikely yeah which
means that the life of the relationship
is limited to say the least
and you're investing all kinds of time
and energy in a woman who is
fundamentally not going to be able to
partner with you in the way that you
want to partner she's not going to be a
wife for you
she's not going to be a mother to your
kids he wants to go check it out on his
own though and if that's and knock
yourself
that's the road you want to go down you
want to try this out cool like knock
yourself out your grown ass man do your
thing right just understand that you're
not actually get out of this what you
think you're going to hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you